beyoncé bien sûr c'est ça merci on l'a
on l'a entre et cours ibo soir qu'est ce
que tu veux le gars le mois le moins
discret du rinadh il arrive c'est le
seul gars qui arrivent et qui déposent
des fiches déjà en tournant à capter
gars
[Applaudissements]
dr
[Musique]
quant à l'épilogué les buts et 16 passes
il a eu déjà iskcon ici il veut pas se
cacher en arrivant mais en partant c'est
bon
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est énorme et c'est lui
le ceva les vignes parce qu'en régie de
nourdine en fait on l'a pas c'est pas
qui met la musique mais je vais aller en
régie et ça va chier des bulles carrière
gvt mois le feu bordel
hélas déjà on n'a pas la musique déjà
tous ces faits ils sont arrêtés avec
tigery bourgi les escales t alors c'est
difficile ici que ne partent pas tous
les sous de touche pas à mon poste
voilà vous savez les sons qui parquent
baba simon merci mais je n'écris a
toujours un petit temps ça arrive
maintenant alors je vais te dire
pourquoi il ya des personnes en régie
qui sont là en emploi précaire
je vais vous raconter l'histoire du son
c'est quand même ouf croyez pas de sens
tout à l'heure non c'est que tu es un
gars de jeu de ces huit pays franchement
c'est mon héros enfin qu'il avait
débranché le dos pour mettre son faux
son chargeur de paris monsieur conserver
que la police a régi déjeuner c'est
comme un tremblement de terre
celui-là mais que tu fais mais qu'est ce
que tu fais là toi justin bieber qu'est
ce que tu fais comme ton est tombé s'il
me demande mon micro mais il est tombé
du snese et rien d'autre pour le maître
se débrouiller tout seul monsieur que
vous serez crabiers comment analyser
alizé elles seront analysées
ouais j'aime bien vos délires beaux
draps des lits réaliser moi je m'appelle
lolita collégienne au bas de bleu mais
[Musique]
je vais vous dire pour votre scoop
maintenant j'ai deux buzzer il ya un
buzzer merci donc si jacky là ça fait si
je m'en fous complètement ça va être ça
merci il va bien voyante avant ce serait
fort enjeu voilà c'est ça m'intéresse
on sort
sheila c'est ça aussi
[Musique]
les paquets
athènes
et
on nous dit que les détournements sont
en marche
merci on vous rappellera milieu est ce
qu'on peut voir justin est ce qu'on peut
voir la photo de la présidente la mer
s'il vous plaît on peut la voir la photo
qui est cette personne y est cette
personne
si on perd on peut voir la personne la
personne bordel
blanchet des images de l'écran derrière
ou pas des vidéos mais pas des photos
c'est loupé l'émission d'image du jour